and breaking news tonight an actor is
accused of being a child rapist and a
cult leader uh you might remember Nathan
chasing horse from the film Dances with
Wolves well he's facing numerous
allegations tonight that he victimized
women and children for years it's a
story of the eight news now
investigators have been working on
tonight Vanessa Murphy obtained details
now from the investigation
Nathan chasing horse is accused of
running a cult and sexually assaulting
indigenous girls for years sources say
in some cases he's believed to have
recorded himself committing these crimes
and one alleged victim is as young as 14
years old now police say he lives here
in this North Las Vegas home with
several wives and he could have as many
as six we've learned he's also accused
of targeting girls in need telling them
Spirits wanted them to have sex with him
and promising them they'd be part of
quote the circle now this is the SWAT
team here earlier one concern as police
were moving in to make the arrest was
possible unsecured Firearms even with
children present at times and sources
say investigators believed Nathan
chasing horse may have had a plan if
police were to show up he's accused of
advising the women present to take
suicide pills and be ready for a
shootout now police also saying Nathan
chasing horse exploited his influence
acting as if he's a spiritual leader in
the Native American Community to lure
vulnerable indigenous girls even taking
them across state lines they say he
targeted girls from single parent homes
without a father figure groomed them and
abused them sexually and physically
repeatedly Nathan chasing horse also
accused of sex trafficking victims
police say he also gave victims
emergency contraceptive pills after
having sex with them to prevent
pregnancies investigators believe there
are more victims out there and
co-conspirators this is an investigation
with ties to Nevada and other states as
Nathan chasing horse traveled around the
country for ceremonies and even Canada
now as far as the police presence here
investigators are searching for any
documentation Nathan chasing horse may
have had about these alleged crimes
reporting in North Las Vegas Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now